at six o'clock i'm sasha loftis we're
following breaking news tonight metro
police a metro police officer rather has
been taken into custody for armed
robbery at a casino on valley view near
flamingo 33-year-old officer caleb
rogers was detained by casino security
early this morning after an attempted
robbery the 8 news now i-team first
broke this story online this afternoon
rogers has been booked for burglary with
a firearm assault with a deadly weapon
and two counts of robbery with a deadly
weapon he has been an officer with metro
since 2015 and serves at bolden area
command i-team sources also believe he
could be linked to an armed robbery at
red rock casino resort on november 12th
and an armed robbery at north las vegas
near aliante and the 2 15 on january 6.
steve gramas president of las vegas
police protective association told the
i-team that he is aware of the
allegations against rogers in an
official statement he says quote the
lvpa is aware of the arrest of officer
rogers while everyone has a presumption
of innocence until proven guilty if
these allegations are true the lvpa
could not be more disappointed and
disgusted by the actions of one rogue
officer end quote rogers is due in court
tomorrow at 9 a.m we will continue to
follow this story closely and of course
have all the details online at 8 news
now dot com